republican legislators in south dakota
have crafted a bill called the kova 19
vaccine freedom of conscience act to
stop employers from forcing their
workers to get the cova vaccine but
christy gnome the republican governor of
the state is refusing to sign it she
argues that
employees who don't want to be
vaccinated can just go work somewhere
else if you don't want to inject this
substance into your body go get a new
job she says also as she stated on
wednesday
if she dictates vaccine policy to
businesses quote unquote then joe biden
can do the same
now this is a bizarre argument as it
suggests that the president of the
united states is looking to the governor
of south dakota for guidance or as a
precedent
but the president united states like a
true democrat doesn't even look to the
constitution or the supreme court much
less to christy gnome of south dakota he
simply does what he wants and he enacts
the policies that he prefers without any
concern for what anyone did before him
where was the precedent for the
executive branch telling all landlords
across the country that they can't evict
delinquent tenants
biden admitted that there was no
precedent that it wasn't even legal to
do it and yet he did it
but this is the difference between
democrats and feckless republicans
democrats use the power that they've
been granted
and then they seize additional power
that they were not granted on top of it
republicans oftentimes most times i
would say
will not even use the legitimate
authority of the offices they hold for
fear that if they act
democrats will also act
they'd rather let the democrats act on
their own with no response or opposition
it's better to you know not get into a
fight with your opponent better to lay
down and let them stomp you into the
dust
because if you fight back it might hurt
even more
that seems to be the republican approach
even more than with the vaccine issue
gnome exemplified this way of thinking a
few months ago when she refused to sign
another republican bill which we talked
about at the time this one would have
banned biological males from competing
in female sports noam said she didn't
want to extend the ban all the way into
the collegiate level because if they do
that
then the ncaa might in her words quote
punish us
she didn't want to take a stand for
science and common sense and truth and
decency and reason for fear that such a
stand would provoke the ire of people
whose ire is constantly provoked anyway
also i suspect that it's not a
coincidence that the gnome's view on the
issue lined up perfectly with the south
dakota chamber of commerce which opposed
the bill gnome typically finds herself
in alignment with the chamber of
commerce like a typical republican and i
don't mean that as a compliment
i also was admittedly not complimenting
christinom yesterday on this show which
you may have heard
when i theorized openly that uh her
population popularity on the right was
due to her looks she's an attractive
woman especially by political standards
and this
i said yesterday
and still say today
explains in my opinion why she garners
all of the hype that she does
now i didn't say that her looks are the
sole reason why she's the governor of
south dakota i didn't say it's why she
has achieved any political success at
all
i said that her emergence as a
conservative icon on the national stage
is due in large part to her appearance
it's true that you know noam never
locked down her state and a lot of
people were very a lot of people on the
right were happy about that she garnered
applause on the right for that
well-deserved applause i i still applaud
her for it
but other republican governors also
refused to instate statewide uh
lockdowns or statewide mass mandates and
yet many of them have not gotten the
kind of attention that she attracts
take the republican governor of nebraska
pete ricketts
let's take a look at what he looks like
now
there's peter i don't mean to insult him
he's a fine looking person in his own
way i'm sure but i
i think he will have to work a little
bit harder
to get the kind of attention that
christy gnome gets
okay and the reason is obvious
it's obvious and yet it's one of the
many obvious things we're not supposed
to say out loud
we all know that there are certain
benefits and privileges that come with
being a physically attractive person we
hear a lot about privilege
okay
hot privilege that's a real that's real
privilege and there are many scientific
studies that prove this uh generally and
also specifically when it comes to
politicians
there are many of these privileges that
come with especially being an attractive
woman even more so
now we all know that
every one of us without exception we all
know that
and yet if you vocally acknowledge this
thing that we all know and agree with
every single one of us
you'll be condemned as a misogynist
now that was my experience yesterday
after discussing the subject on my show
criticizing gnome for her policies and
her lack of political courage and then
suggesting that her popularity is due
more to her physical features
um
media matters as is their custom clipped
that part of the program and posted it
to their website and to twitter
trying to gin up some outrage
and the attempt fell rather flat at
first frankly i was myself disappointed
by their selection because i said many
more objectionable things on the show
yesterday and i would have preferred
that they'd chosen one of those segments
instead i mean i knew they were going to
choose something because they always do
and they went with that and my first
reaction was this is what you guys are
going with
of all of the things i said
this
that people are gravitating towards a
particular politician because of how she
looks that's the supposedly offensive
thing
nobody reacted much or cared um about it
until
christinome herself the governor of
south dakota
took that media matters clip cut it down
even shorter to remove the context and
the reason for my criticism
focusing only on the part where i
comment on her looks
and posted it to her own twitter page
her actually in fact her official
governor twitter page along with this
caption it read quote instead of
engaging in a debate about the proper
role of government and how it isn't
conservative to tell people how to do
business
matt walsh stooped to horrible misogyny
eyes up here matt
but she wasn't done she then went to her
personal page
and posted again this time also telling
on me to my boss by tagging ben shapiro
and she said quote hey ben shapiro tell
matt walsh i was roping bulls maybe he's
a steer bigger than him when i was in my
teens he couldn't walk a day in my shoes
girl power
and she's right i probably wouldn't fit
in her shoes but if she was a college
athlete i could take her place on the
team according to her policies
by the way let's note that a steer okay
is a castrated bull
so that's the dig she was trying to make
there which is fine okay pretty good
insult i'm not offended by it
um
i dish it i can take it but you can't go
for the ruthless insult while also
tattling on me to my boss
hey
guess what matt said ben
and also crying about horrible misogyny
you really got to pick a lane christy
you're either the toughest nails woman
riding in on your horse roping bulls
or you're a fragile feminist accusing
your critics of misogyny it's got to be
one of the other
or might i suggest you could choose
neither of those characters because they
both ring false
the rough and tumble girl power shtick
is especially inauthentic
seeing as how you know you'll go head to
head with a right wing podcast host
while kowtowing to corporate interests
and the lgbt lobby
i mean where was where were these
where was this backbone
the all the courage here where was this
when the when the ncaa was coming after
her no they'll punish us not the ncaa i
don't want to be punished
and what about this misogyny charge
is it is it sexist is it anti-woman for
me to accuse christinome of benefiting
politically from her physical
attractiveness no it isn't because for
one thing again it's true
and everybody knows that it's true
you can argue about the extent to which
it has helped but if you tell me that it
hasn't helped at all then i'm way off in
left field here
then i will know that you're either
stupid or lying
but let's pretend for a moment
that the accusation is not true
okay let's say that i am off in left
field
well then that would make me wrong it
would make me unfair perhaps even a jerk
it would make me many things potentially
and i may be all of those things
it still wouldn't make me sexist though
because i heep extremely harsh criticism
on politicians all the time it's one of
my favorite pastimes and i believe it
should be a favorite pastime of all
red-blooded americans
i criticize male and female politicians
alike
i mean go back to some of the shows
where i was talking about asa hutchinson
governor asa hutchinson when he
refused to sign the bill banning the
castration of children
go check out some of the things i said
about him
quite a bit harsher in fact
now is all of my criticism of
politicians accurate
and most of it is yeah well actually all
of it is i think but but even if it
isn't
the criticism is motivated by my dislike
for politicians
especially the ones that i consider to
be weak ineffectual and dishonest
it's not motivated by dislike for women
now it's probably pointless for me to
explain all this because the explanation
presupposes that the accusation was
sincere and honest in the first place
which it wasn't
no one was using a leftist buzzword and
trying to gin up left-wing outrage
against me in order to make herself the
victim and that brings us to the most
important point
and the reason that i'm talking about
all of this
here we see the critical mistake that
conservatives so often make especially
elected republicans who call themselves
conservative
gnome was using a media matters clip
and leftist language
to hit someone to the right of her
hoping to win favorability points among
people to the left of her
there'd be no other reason to do that
you're not going to be using media
matters and using the word misogynist
and attacking someone to your right
if you're trying to appeal to people to
your right
now this was a play for people to her
left
did it work
uh no not remotely check social media
today to see what folks on the left are
saying about the christie gnome versus
matt walsh feud and you'll find that
they are in wide agreement
that were both terrible people and scum
of the earth and disgraceful ignoramuses
and so on
the sympathy that gnome has gotten has
come in the form of comments like this
from a guy named brian rosenwald this is
pretty
pretty representative of the kind of
things people are saying says i think
christine is terrible and her decisions
have cost people their lives but matt
walsh's comments were the purest form of
misogyny you'll ever see
he wouldn't say the same things about
ron desantis with a similar profile
it's a firing offense
but it's conservative media
well she got her wish in one respect um
people are calling for me to be fired
and yet and that obviously is what she
wanted that's again why she tagged my
boss in a tweet
and yet the people calling for me to be
fired still say that gnome herself is a
mass murdering monster
and she is
in the same way that i'm a misogynist at
least
we have seen republicans make this
mistake a thousand times thousands and
thousands of times
they criticize their own side
using leftist frameworks
in hopes of impressing the left
and then the whole thing just collapses
on them
and they're the only one who gets
crushed in the end
and that's the lesson that hopefully
we all can learn
from this
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content